I just spoke moments ago by the way
exclusively with Homeland Security
Secretary Kristen Nielsen about her
relationship with the president and
pressing immigration issues great to
have you Madam Secretary thank you for
coming to the set tonight so you had a
big fiery hearing on Capitol Hill today
I know that yeah yeah it so it's always
fun and so this was this is a big day
for you Kamala Harris decided to hit you
on the issue of separating children from
their parents let's watch your agency
will be separating children from their
parents and those what we'll be doing is
prosecuting parents who have broken the
law just as we do every day in the
United States of America I can
appreciate that but if that parent has a
four-year-old child what do you plan on
doing with that child the child under
law goes to HHS for care and custody
they will be separated from their
parents yes I might do in the United
States every day
it's the immigration sob story as we
call it on the radio which is not to be
diminished
these are heartbreaking situations yeah
how do you as DHS secretary combat which
the the emotional push on this how can
you do this and you kept saying well
basically this is the law how do you
deal with that well it is the law as you
know and you know I had an exchange last
week with a different senator that tried
to cut me off and so do I know this is
your philosophy and I said ma'am it's
not a philosophy it's the law if you
enter our country illegally we will
refer you for prosecution we will
prosecute you but as you know for every
sob story we have 73 percent border
assault increase with people like Kate
Steinle I mean where is the compassion
for the flip side of this conversation
the American people don't get the same
treatment from Kamala Harris and others
who will be quoting tonight in the show
because it's always a one-way street and
I think those who are in charge or
charged with actually enforcing the law
are always meant to be the bad guys and
yet the American citizens elected Donald
Trump because they wanted that situation
reversed it's America first you've
actually done a lot and a lot of this
doesn't get discussed h-1b visa abuse
that's bringing in foreign worker bees
you're working with DOJ
you're working on other ways to protect
the American worker one of the things
that is really frustrating is this
asylum fraud
we've been documenting it on the show we
have American lawyers flying down to
Mexico coaching clients sorry they say
it's advising clients what can you do on
an executive level if Congress doesn't
get off its backside and get this done
it's really frustrating I've got to be
honest I really share the the
president's frustration on this and that
of the American people I mean the way
the system works right now the threshold
under law is so low that about 80%
passed that initial interview but only
20% are granted asylum by a judge which
tells us that 80% of that is either just
a flat-out fraud or somebody who thinks
they can come here because they want a
job here that's not Asylum
well I want to reunify with my family
that's not Asylum well I just would like
to come to the United States not Asylum
we have legal ways to do that but it's
not through Asylum but we hear that
there might be another caravan making
its way up from Canberra I don't know
where we got the name caravan but
caravan I guess it's a biblical or
people are coming up again because they
feel like as long as they get to the
border they can get into the country and
they will ultimately be released correct
or they not being released well we're
we're metering which means that if we
don't have the resources to let them in
on a particular day they're gonna have
to come back so they're gonna have to
wait their turn and we will process them
as we can but that's the way that the
law works once they come into the United
States we process them so we've asked
Congress to fix the supo it's a huge
gaping loophole that we need fix because
it's so abused one of the other things
that I think is it's very frustrating to
the American people is the fact that we
have these repeat border crossers people
who've jumped the border multiple times
have been deported come back into the
country and yet they still get the oh my
gosh what are you gonna do about the
poor immigrants our communities are
being shattered because of this
enforcement you have actually overseen a
huge increase in border enforcement and
workplace enforcement raids and so forth
which I think are being welcomed by the
American people but again the media and
the Democrats are hitting you for
shattering communities yeah but let's
get back to Kate Steinle I mean it's how
sad is it the
the Congress of the United States can't
pass a law to simply increase penalties
for criminals who have been deported who
come back the House passed it we can't
get the Senate to pass it also in
communities you know we just broke
through a stash house last week the
gentleman had been deported four times
and had finals ordered orders of removal
five times and we're still dealing with
him because we can't completely the
system doesn't work so he deport him and
he comes back which is why as you know
we need a wall what's happening with the
National what's happening with the
National Guard at the border that was a
big controversy here in Washington I
travel the country a lot
it seemed again like the people are
saying well it's about time I heard that
on radio all the time people calling in
I don't get the National Guard at the
border why would get extra help you have
news on more troops now you're going to
the border told ya that very
appreciative of the support of secretary
Madison department defense so is you
know we about 1600 now with our second
request we'll have about 22 hundred
originally we were focused on Border
Patrol support but now we've extended it
so we're gonna support the folks at the
ports of entry and then also our Intel
an analysis but it's a huge first
multiplier huge force multiplier
California Jerry Brown saying we're not
going to be assisting in immigration
enforcement what are the California
National Guard troops actually doing
they they are supporting CBP they're
just doing it behind the scenes there
are specific things that we've worked
out so they are supporting we want each
governor to do more I've talked to each
governor talked about once a month to
give them the new border figures what
we're doing we'll continue to try to get
California do more we just talked to Bob
Goodlatte on the show and he he's very
concerned about these immigration
centrists I call them liberal liberal
Republicans who are pushing this new
daca amnesty right now we're trying to
through this discharge petition work
with the Democrats get it rammed through
the House of Representatives at least
what do you want Congress to do and this
president to get this immigration
enforcement done the right way in order
to satisfy his promises to the American
people I think the president has been
very clear on this and it's very easy we
need a wall we need to close the
loopholes and that we need the personnel
and resources that we need so
apprehension without detention and
removal is not border security so we've
got to have the beds
so we got to be able to apprehend detain
and then remove so that's judges that's
lawyers that detention beds but it's not
it's a very easy formula to have border
security when border security is part
and parcel to the sovereignty of a
nation how many people about cross the
border last month in the United States
family unit yeah so take take the the
original Caravan location we have about
a hundred thousand people that cross
that that port of entry each day so most
of that is legal traffic but again we're
talking about you know millions hundreds
of millions of people that crossed one
was about 1.1 each day between the two
borders so it's a lot of traffic but
buried in there of course are those who
are seeking to abuse the system it's a
broken system we've got a we've got to
work with Congress Congress has got to
close these loopholes we have a two
hundred three percent increase in
illegal border crossings from March 2017
to March 2018 I think by family units
overall it's a huge increase what why
what's going well I think they know the
two couple things some of the loopholes
are they know if they cross between the
ports of entry that nothing will happen
if they bring kids they'll be released
the kids will be released in 20 days
under a court case right if their
criminal they'll serve a little bit of
time but under a different court case we
have to release them in six months back
into the communities the criminals if
they're other than Mexican we can't put
them in expedited removal if there's
children involved so they know they you
know they know better than Congress they
know better than most of us the
smugglers so they know the loopholes
they're exploiting them are you and the
president good now there was some
concern last week
he's very impatient for change I've
noticed that secretary it can be a
patient he's frustrated rightly so I
mean can you imagine here's the
president of United States saying I want
to secure this country Americans must
come first and Congress is saying yeah
we're we don't have time we're busy we
got to on recess you're here for the
long haul I am yes ma'am it's great to
see you thank you so much my pleasure I
really appreciate thank you